in the Banner Saga you'll be embarking  on a grueling journey that will be every  bit as brutal at times as it is  beautiful to help you get through those  moments were arming you with the aptly  named insane Viking pack  the insane Viking pack includes an  exclusive character called trig V treat  V is very well known in his hometown  where he's mostly avoided due to his  raucous nature yes he's a troublemaker  and a little unstable however there's no  denying his weight in combat as a  skilled spin and you're a wise man to  engage his services to fight on your  side his necklace with matching full and  Halfmoon symbols is made of pearl and he  believes they aligned to give him luck  finally you'll also get three exclusive  tracks from the game's original music  score by grammy nominated composer  Austin Wintory  to learn more about the game visit our  forums website and Facebook page